agent carla mendoza was one of the best
field agents that site 41 had ever seen
she was professional cool under pressure
and when the situation demanded it she
could be a straight up badass during a
chaos insurgency raid on the site she'd
single-handedly killed four different
insurgents the last one with her bare
hands during containment breaches she'd
always be the first one charging into
the fray her foundation standard issue
beretta drawn and ready to fire agent
mendoza was so devoted to the job that
she took up the site director's offer to
start living on site so she could always
be there to help if an emergency
situation unfolded after all when it all
hits the fan you want someone as utterly
unshakable as agent mendoza on your side
the job had thrown the worst of the
worst at her and she'd never even
flinched so surely nothing could scare
agent mendoza
right
after a long day of kicking ass taking
names and filling in the properly
mandated amount of scp foundation
debriefing paperwork agent mendoza
retired to her site 41 quarters she felt
exhausted and sweaty so before heading
to bed to watch some wonderful scp
explained videos on her phone how kind
she decided to take a quick shower the
last thing she expected was for this
particular shower to become
well let's say
hitchcockian the water was running hot
and clean filling the air with steam
agent mendoza was lathering up her hair
when she first heard the noise heavy
wheezing breaths coming from just behind
the shower curtain the second she heard
it agent mendoza felt a kind of brutal
crushing anxiety that she'd never
experienced before like a hand was
reaching into her chest and squeezing
her heart the self-defense training that
had been encoded into her muscle memory
over years of working at the foundation
kicked into effect in a blind panic she
struck out at the shower curtain causing
it to sway outwards and land directly on
the face of mendoza's wheezing voyeur
who or whatever it was it was standing
right there less than a meter away from
the shower the wheezing carved into
mendoza's ears like a butcher's knife
what an awful monstrous sound and
despite the fact that the shower curtain
obscured its face she could still
somehow see it the way a defenseless
animal can sense an approaching predator
without ever locking eyes on it and just
somehow know that it's too late for them
to escape now
every training session every achievement
every piece of battle hardening
experience it all evaporated in the
presence of that
thing
mendoza was so terrified she might as
well have been a child the monster just
stood there beyond the curtain its raw
fleshy face parted into a freakishly
wide yellow-toothed grin she didn't know
how but on some deep primal level she
was aware that if this thing got its
hands on her something horrific beyond
description would happen to her she was
too terrified to even move a muscle in
its presence she remained like that
standing in the shower and sobbing
quietly for the next three solid hours
until the creature finally disappeared
when her colleagues found her she'd
experienced moderate scalding wounds
from the hot water of the shower it took
several hours for agent mendoza to
compose herself enough to share her
story a couple days later tim ellis a
junior level filing clerk was found
trapped in a site-41 supply closet he'd
urinated in his foundation-issued slacks
and was in a state of borderline
catatonia when his superiors asked him
why he'd been spending two hours in a
supply closet on company time he
reported that it was because a monster
had appeared outside the door when he
was searching for a replacement stapler
despite never actually opening the door
to see what was outside or call for help
mr ellis said that he felt as though he
would have had a heart attack if he
actually opened that accursed door he
was able to provide a clear description
of the monster he said it was tall and
emaciated with reddish-brown skin that
made it seem almost burnt or rotten
while it stood there and waited beyond
the supply closet door it let out the
most awful wheezing noise like an old
rusty iron lung but the image that ellis
seemed most fixated on was the monster's
face or lack thereof
just a huge grinning mouth that covered
up its entire head stalked with an
arsenal of massive yellow teeth ellis
was visibly shivering as he talked about
it two incidents are an unpleasant
coincidence but three are a bona fide
pattern and it didn't take long for more
sightings of this strange new anomaly
dubbed scp-303 or the doorman to pop up
across the site it earned that name by
always appearing behind some kind of
doorway or at least a movable divider in
the case of agent mendoza's shower
curtain whenever it appeared outside a
doorway nearby foundation personnel
would report being struck with a sudden
paralyzing terror that made engaging
with the creature impossible attempts to
call for help were also often stifled as
the very presence of the doorman causes
disruptions to electrical equipment
whenever the doorman manifests in your
proximity it's safe to say that it'll be
commanding your absolute undivided
attention this was a particularly
frightening case for the scp foundation
because it was one of the few anomalies
bringing the fight directly to them most
sentient anomalous beings would do
anything to avoid getting captured by
the scp foundation and contained in one
of their high security sites full of
experienced researchers and
state-of-the-art equipment designed
specifically to neutralize their effects
the doorman however just seemed to take
this as a challenge turning even the
most hardcore personnel on the site into
jibbering wrecks with its mere presence
but the doorman was just getting started
agent henderson had a frightening
encounter in the break room he was
pulling a long shift and just wanted to
grab some coffee creamer from the
cabinet however as he approached the
cabinet he heard the telltale wheezing
and that terrible overwhelming terror
set in once more the doorman was sitting
inside the cabinet in a fetal position
he just knew it could this thing really
appear just anywhere as it pleased and
keep people in or out until it decided
to dematerialize and torment somebody
else when the creature finally
dematerialized and the cabinet was
examined the coffee creamer was found to
be missing leaving agent henderson
distraught this was the first recorded
instance of the doorman stealing a
physical item but it would be far from
the last henderson wondered whether the
creature that had just humiliated him
was sitting somewhere else now sipping
from a warm cup of joe with its big
freakish mouth and laughing at him but a
few incidents after this
things would become considerably more
serious the doorman was about to take
its first life well it isn't really that
simple if you want to get into the
semantics of the thing when the body of
dr barker was found inside the second
floor storage room after a spree of
scp-303 incidents the question was
naturally posed as to whether the
doorman had gotten more dangerous and
finally directly attacked one of its
victims not quite there had only been
one way in and out of the storage room a
secured decompression chamber and the
doorman had appeared inside this chamber
while dr barker was in the storage room
effectively trapping him inside with the
sheer terror it causes in its victims he
was trapped in the room for a grand
total of five days at which point he
finally died of dehydration and the
doorman demanifested shortly afterward
the staff of site 41 scaled up their
countermeasure efforts hoping to
discover more about and perhaps even
trap and contain the infamous doorman dr
burroughs researcher matthews four
members of security personnel and four
d-class operatives formed a kind of
strike team ready for quick dispatches
whenever the doorman happened to
manifest it wasn't long before the
creature appeared in a room on the first
floor but the team quickly intercepted
its location ready and eager to gather
more data on the mysterious being that
had been terrorizing them all for weeks
dr burroughs ordered one of the
d-classes to open the door and look
inside but the d-class refused out of
fear the doctor told him that if he
didn't open the door he'd be transferred
to scp-682 duty the d-class frantically
shook his head and said i'd rather take
my chances with the reptile than go in
there the doctor was getting frustrated
he told the d-class that if he didn't
open the door immediately he'd be
terminated right there on the spot the
d-class still refused saying that he'd
take death over what the doorman would
do to him if he stepped inside without
hesitation dr burroughs ordered one of
the security officers to shoot the
d-class then and there the shot was
fired the d-class was terminated dr
burroughs then ordered a female d-class
who just witnessed this callous
execution to open the door or the same
abrupt death would befall her she still
refused then began to describe the awful
things she believed the doorman would do
to her if she went inside researcher
matthews was visibly shaken by the
description dr burroughs decided not to
terminate this d-class immediately he
instead wanted to see just how much
pressure the doorman's anomalous
fear-based resistance mechanisms could
take another d-class was given a combat
knife then also given the order to cut
the female d-class with it every time
she refused and ordered to go inside
after two hours of repeated asking from
dr burrows the female d-class dropped
dead from blood loss at no point did she
ever attempt to open the door it seemed
that in all the cases for those in the
thrall of the doorman's anomalous
effects death is a truly preferable
alternative to ever facing it head-on
it's worth mentioning that these tests
were conducted back in the 1970s before
the formation of the foundation's ethics
committee which explains why their
methods feel a little needlessly cruel
since then the doorman has fully
commandeered the second floor storage
room the same one where it caused dr
barker's death it only leaves the room
to steal more items from around the site
these items have include a cryotube
three sets of standard foundation
surgical equipment two d-class research
cadavers one gasoline-powered generator
a variety of chemicals from the chemical
storage areas and of course poor agent
henderson's can of powdered coffee
creamer the reason for the doorman
taking an interest in these particular
items remains unknown but we can only
assume that nothing good can come of it
and there you have it folks the strange
frightening and eerily inconclusive tale
of the doorman all we can really say is
that we're awfully glad he's fixated on
bothering site 41 because who knows what
would happen if he widened his net to
the rest of us thankfully we won't need
to think about that oh that's odd can
you hear that i thought i was imagining
it so come to think of it i can't help
it feel a little uneasy right now do you
ever get that feeling that you're being
watched wait the door there's something
behind the door can you feel it can you
feel its red flesh and rotten teeth
pressing up against it breathing
waiting can you feel it staring at you
without eyes looking deep into your very
soul
well that's good but just stay cautious
okay after all life has many doors had
boy and you never know who or what will
be waiting for you behind the next one
now go check out the deadliest game
scp-1918
tic-tac-toe and
scp-1861 the crew of the hms winter
shimmer for more genuinely frightening
anomalies that'll keep you up at night